transformation moment it's the moment
that you really like see the character
staring back at you the new series The
Rings of power has made quite a splash
among audiences as the highest budget
Series in history this show is nothing
if not visually amazing but how was it
for the actors to wear the makeup
Prosthetics and costumes required to
create these characters we've got all
the behind the scenes details so buckle
in a lot of Blood Sweat and Tears have
gone into this number one These Boots
Were Made for strength training
according to Sofia nombetti who plays
Princess disa her gold boots gave her
quads of Steel by the end of the Run
instead that they were a few kilos per
boot number two to transform human
actors into the kinds of creatures we
see in the rings of power Universe it's
no surprise that it takes a bit longer
in the makeup chair than it takes your
average person to do their eyeliner for
the day we were still surprised by just
how time consuming these makeup routines
were though a wine Arthur who plays
during the fourth appeared at the Lord
of the Rings the rings of power panel at
San Diego Comic-Con and he talked to
fans about just how long it took to
change his appearance apparently before
every shoot Arthur spent three hours
getting makeup and Prosthetics applied
but that wasn't all it took him about 45
minutes to get the makeup removed each
day after filming number three we can
all agree that a wine Arthur is totally
unrecognizable as Prince Duren IV and
while there are clearly plenty of facial
Prosthetics at work to turn him into a
totally different species one major
difference is the beard this beard
actually came in 16 separate pieces a
goal with Durham the forced facial hair
was that it needed to allow Arthur to
move his face freely and have the beard
move without it pulling on his skin or
making it hard to make any facial
expressions you know like a real beard
his entire hair situation was composed
of a wig and mustache plus neck hairs
sideburns and under beard chin pieces
and even nostril hair to answer your
inevitable next question yes it was
human hair it was also partially hoarse
and gory goat and Yak hair and according
to Arthur it weighed as much as a
newborn baby Jane O'Kane the head of the
makeup and hair Department called it an
extensive jigsaw puzzle of facial hair
number four have you ever heard of nose
cones nose Cones were one of the many
tiny pieces of Duran the force
incredible beard according to Arthur
they attached to the edge of the nose
and curled upwards we definitely never
thought of the tiny hairs around
someone's nose as an important part of a
beard but that's probably why this beard
looks so realistic number five if you
like us are trying to imagine wearing a
16-piece beard that weighs as much as a
human baby while also sporting a fake
nose tons of makeup and layers upon
layers of clothes now try to imagine
doing all that in the summertime in New
Zealand yeah we need an ice cold
lemonade and to stick our heads in the
freezer just thinking about it yet
that's exactly what a wine Arthur and
the cast experienced as they shot the
rings of power's first season from
February through August to make this
process at least a little easier Arthur
sported a cooling vest when he underwent
his intense makeup routine number six
during the fourth is a super short dwarf
the actor who plays him a wine Arthur on
the other hand is five foot nine so what
kind of amazing movie Magic and special
effects went into making him look
smaller a lot less than you think
actually Arthur simply got down on his
knees while his fellow actors stood on
ladders number seven if you watch the
rings of power's first few episodes
there's probably one thing in particular
that comes to mind when you think about
the series's makeup and Prosthetics
those prosthetic elf ears the ears don't
even look fake the only way we know that
they're Prosthetics is because we know
that morphid Clark who plays Galadriel
isn't an actual elf though she is pretty
convincing in this role Clark says
there's an amazing
Prosthetics artist Irina painting them
day and night and says that they were
even painting tiny veins on the ears all
that attention to detail definitely paid
off
number eight it was important to make
the Orcs look realistic as well as bit
with the rest of tolkien's lore all
while allowing the actors who played
them to actually fight as a result the
Orcs Prosthetics were designed to let
them move easily they also have extra
lines scars and wrinkles on their skin
to show the Orcs pasts number nine it
took quite a lot of effort to make the
heart foots look like heart foots as
well sever zangabani plays the hard foot
Marigold Brandy foot and she said that
she was excited to get her costume until
she realized she'd be wearing huge feet
and getting covered in mud she joked
that this was a bit of a come down she
went on to explain that those feet made
things pretty difficult at first but in
her words we had this incredible team of
people who kept refining them and by the
end they became part of us and we didn't
want to take them off number 10 after
seeing all those amazing costumes it's
very clear that cosplayers are going to
be super excited about recreating looks
from the rings of power in reality
though this actually had a little
something to do with the actual costume
design process the costume designer Kate
Hawley set out to make sure that the
inevitable cosplayers would struggle to
replicate her intricate designs and it's
safe to say she did a good job it'll
take a pretty dedicated cosplayer to
make a 16-piece beard but we're sure
somebody at Comic-Con will make it
happen number 11. the Orcs in particular
are pretty amazing to look at and it's
wild to think that creatures like that
aren't actually real Morphin Clark
agrees and says that even though they
know that the Orcs aren't actually real
it's still scary to see them running
towards you yeah that's completely Fair
she does say though they're uniquely
unfightening when they're drinking a
smoothie in between takes Orcs they're
just like us
number 12. so how did those Orcs look so
convincing the Orcs facial Prosthetics
were made from something called
encapsulated silicon this is two layers
of silicon that have a piece of silicon
between them that can move this way they
can move their faces with ease this
means that the new Orcs look a lot more
realistic than those from The Lord of
the Rings The Fellowship of the Ring
back in 2001 according to Jamie Wilson
the head of the prosthetic Department of
the race of power the new materials work
with the actors moving with their skin
and reaching the same temperature as the
actor's skin growing transparent making
the application of the intense orc
makeup that much simpler number 13 wigs
for fantasy series can be a difficult
thing to make look realistic internet
backlash towards a certain other current
fantasy show has proven that to be true
but we aren't naming any names the rings
of power characters on the other hand
have some very convincing hair a core
according to Sophia nombetti her hair
and costumes were what made her
character come alive she added that her
wig garnered the nickname Gloria number
14. with all the work money attention to
detail and incredible amounts of
patience required to make these
characters come to life via costumes and
makeup it's easy to wonder why put the
actors through all of this when it could
all be added in Via CGI well Jamie
Wilson says that it was extremely
important to the folks making this
series that it was all real as possible
in his words there are hundreds of
Productions that are heavy on visual
effects and you can see it that the
human eye is getting better and better
and knows what is real and knows what
isn't number 15 while being in hair and
makeup for so long was certainly
challenging for this cast that doesn't
mean the only upside to the rings of
power makeup with the incredible real
result Sarah zangabani had to spend her
fair share of I'm in the makeup chair to
turn into her hard foot character
Marigold Brandy foot she said I sang
songs with my fellow actors Megan
Richards markella Kavanaugh I talked to
my great team sometimes I just thought
about my character and what I was going
to do for the day two and a half hours
sounds like a long time but we actually
had a great time so it was like No Time
passed what do you think about the
costumes Prosthetics and makeups in the
rings of power how would you feel about
sitting in the makeup chair for hours
before work every day let's talk about
it in the comments and if you love
videos like this one be sure to like And
subscribe to the things for all the
latest in TV and movies